er hat einfach kein erschlägt er nicht
er macht einfach schaden helfen so eine
magische aura
davos s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge der hacker sowie immer
zeige ich euch heute die besten
lustigsten und witzigsten hacker
einsendung der letzten woche wenn ihr
auch mal dabei sein wollt dann ladet
hacker material als ungelöstes video
youtube hoch und schickt mir den link zu
diesem video per privater nachricht
durch wird soviel dazu lasst uns
loslegen mit der ersten sendung die
stammt von hacker und sich gehabt es war
wieder mal ein richtig preis der hacker
ich hoffe dass in den nächsten helga
show zu sehen und so weiter und so fort
alles klar die kreatur boards hoch
ziemlich hoch okay okay was ist falsch
an
jawohl und da würde es mal los
gekleideter wie hoch ist der typ bisher
bis einfach genau das sei irgendwie
scheiße passiert wenn er auf der stelle
steht noch immer fall schaden bekommt
erhält man sich schon so war das kann
jetzt nicht sein doch besser das macht
ihm wieder warum läuft man auf diese
übers spielfeld sich stets komme noch
die idee komme also gegen gleichen haben
sondern nichts unternahmen flein geht
wohl nicht aufgearbeitet aber gleichen
alter job oder herr knopp stadt
vielleicht neue luft stehen natürlich
keine luft stehen sorry es tut mir leid
dass ich nicht gedacht hätte dass in der
luft jetzt kriegt er fall schaden ja
genau der stets von einem chat oder
fällt in skopje preis weil er
wahrscheinlich sonst irgendwie dumme art
und weise falsch abbekommen hätte jetzt
geht da rein elektrisch und springt auch
darunter ok bedient sich mal hier der
kiste ist klar aber die nicht da ist
wird auf jeden fall so zu melden dieses
clips um ein kurzer froberg zu dem
moment wo er einfach da jetzt die hacks
aktiviert den fall schreiben bekommen
und dann losläuft aus der base von tim
roth rüber zur based on the base blau.de
bay city rollers peter port und niemand
eiskalt niemand in dieser runde
irgendwas nicht bekommen ich habe keinen
anderen spieler gesehen aber es waren
sehr viele einstieg wir springen zur
nächsten sendung
die nächste sendung stammt von groupe e
und s genannte hecke auf dem hd sender
games also irgendwie alle hacker sind
aufgabe gemacht noch was in eurem neuen
plug in wird diesmal aber ändern games
hat mir schon lange lange nicht mehr bzw
noch nie in der games deswegen ich hoffe
auf gute unterhaltung filme hat für
diese folge ende games
alles klar drei spiele erst bei kälte
sogar nur noch ihr auto europe teams
berufen wenn dann alles klar
moment mal war die boarder gerade jesu
wie immer die boarder ja weil es
wirklich auto versucht mich sehr auch
für mac pc flickr weg.de gegner wurde
jetzt dahin gepostet oder wie wohl keine
andere sich gerade auf der map ihn
gepackt hat und jetzt top darunter kann
er meldet keine falschen bekommen ok of
water safety schrift ist ein bisschen
ärgerlich aber es klappt es hat auf
jeden fall jetzt holt ein oder wurden
jetzt erholt ihn möglich junge junge
junge
als das habe ich auch nie gesehen dass
einer auf der map fliegen ist es gar
keine strategie mein heckansicht dumm
aber es keine dumme strategie auf web
zufrieden dann sich mit dem gegner
tauschen zu lassen mit dem port und dann
dafür zu sorgen dass die gegner im durch
die boarder schaden bekommt gar nicht so
blöd davon eine allgemeine anmerkung ihr
müsst das jetzt nicht mit schrift aus
kommentiert macht sowas bitte nicht also
jetzt in der folge was in ordnung war
die folge lustig war aber im allgemeinen
es hat am besten nächstes video rein
keine musik dann kann ich alles selbst
einblenden welches vermutlich heute
danke
okay diese 1 sendung stammt von 614 wir
schauen mal was er gefunden hat hier es
ist wohl kaum auf dem monitor busses
treffen wir kein alles klar die
todeskino fakt achtem auf den typen
achte mal auf den er macht ihm eiskalt
schaden ohne ihn zu schlagen guck mal
es schlägt die nicht mal ist der geräte
vor schaden er ist keine eiskalt keine
schlagbewegung von ihm da das einzige
was ich mir erklären könnte ist dass er
irgendwie ein hack drin hat dass er so
schnell zuschlägt dass die schlag
animation ich mal kommt es gibt glaube
ich hatte trank er hat einfach kein
erschlägt er fertigt er macht einfach
schaden helfe so eine magische aura
alles klar da sieht man es ist keine
schlagbewegung da wieder die frage an
euch raus an den schwarm ist das wie
kann man sich das erkennen ist ja keine
schlagbewegung ist es wirklich so dass
es so schnell zuschlägt dass die
animation nicht mal kommt für den schlag
oder gibt es dafür eine andere erklärung
wenn eine idee hat wie immer ab damit in
die kommentare
lass uns da fleißig diskutieren
die stammt von master de und er schreibt
das ist so gut ich habe mich beim zocken
nicht mehr eingekriegt gebe schon rein
film ab es ist schon mal wieder etwas
also habe ich ein anderes bett wars
ziemlich ziemlich ziemlich hacker
verseucht ist okay soweit alles endet
die sich schon wieder goma wiederkomme
und schon wieder war es aber soweit
sieht alles ganz normal aus ok past and
respond dahinten krieg noch taxi alles
ganz normal das passt zu weit
eigentlich alles ziemlich normal würde
ich sagen wollte spawnen alles klar
moment mal wasser das ja die schiene
drin er fliegt einfach raus worte [ __ ]
mann wie dreist wieder mal ich weiß es
über lieblings wolbecker chance es
wirklich so kann man leider award die
leute ein und der eine fliegt einfach
raus eiskalt jedes mal aufbauen und
wieder fix an
ich dachte man kann aufkommen nicht frei
hätten warum geht das
ich dachte man kann auf kommando kleiden
wie ist das schreibt in die kommentare
wenn ihr wisst wie die frage ist kann
man kann man auf kommen wirklich fliegen
oder kann man nur bleiben weil der
fliegt ja offensichtlich wollte jetzt
hier ab alles natürlich hat er klug
gemacht hat nachdem freiheit so zu
treppen als portier anderes bett ab
flieg flieg weg wieder eingebaut kann
man alter oder jetzt macht er um auf dem
die profis jedoch weg also leipzig
kennen lassen
sk
xe gestellt also ich hab ja den
aufnehmenden und ein hacker im verdacht
dass die vielleicht zusammen gearbeitet
haben
was ist auch mal um ein thema da bot er
mich um den block aber lässt er
wegfliegen wort der wieder etwas zurück
die ctp und er wird seitdem peace ich
glaube ganz ehrlich ja mit mir
zusammengearbeitet was man dir ist es
eine verschwörung zwischen hacker und
den typen der aufgenommen hat oder nicht
schreibt auch das gerne an die
kommentare so leute in diesem sinne
danke fürs zuschauen bei dieser folge
hacker steuerlast immer gerne daumen
nach oben da und diskutiert in den
kommentaren was da es wahrhaben genug
themen würde ich sagen ich freue mich
auf die nächste folge jeden sonntag gibt
der neue folge hacker der sich das
gefallen hat könnt ihr auch gerne mal
ein anderkonto der beim 'club' checken
ich stoppe das war so was von mir auch
reinmacht gut und einen schönen tag